news voice is the world's first mobile
app that helps you track
where your news is coming from news
voice helps you track what corporate
interests might be influencing the
narratives in the news you read every
day
arm yourself against corporate media
monopolies by downloading the news voice
app
for free using the link right underneath
this video
so now i do want to play for you just
some clips of donald trump's dr sean
connelly
deceiving and juking and disorienting
the public over the weekend about donald
trump's health
so on saturday morning sean conley came
out with an army of doctors standing
behind him
to tell us everything is supposedly
great except that he didn't this was one
of the biggest
disasters in crisis management
he created a crisis by coming out and
obviously lying about how great
everything is going
it started to get weird with dr sean
connelly when he was asked whether
donald trump had been on supplemental
oxygen
and conley insisted trump didn't need
oxygen
that day i'm gonna try to pin you down
one more time i know you said there's no
other yeah
yeah he's not on oxygen
and he's what's today saturday uh no
no thursday no thursday no friday
saturday that's fine so that was why we
were
thursday no oxygen none at this moment
yeah and yesterday with the team
uh well we were all here he was not on
oxygen
so he says none thursday none at walter
reed friday
and none today which was saturday now of
course now we know
trump had oxygen friday at the white
house
really bad lying it was obvious that
sean connelly
was lying sean connelly also mentioned
and this might be a case of accidentally
telling the truth
sean connolly mentioned trump had now
been this was saturday morning
conley said trump had been in treatment
72 hours
wait a second 72 hours from saturday
morning that puts us friday morning
thursday morning wednesday morning
publicly donald trump supposedly didn't
test positive till 1am friday morning
he's been in treatment for 72 hours
that's weird take a listen
as reported yesterday consultation with
this group
i recommended we bring the president up
to walter reed
as a precautionary measure to provide
state of the art monitoring and any care
that he may need
just 72 hours into the diagnosis now the
first week of covid and a particular day
7-10 of the most critical
later conley put out a statement saying
i made a mistake
i just made a mistake about how long it
had been not very convincing for the
doctor who supposedly
has been involved in trump's treatment
every step of the way conley also said
trump had no fever for a while minutes
later we got a report that trump had a
fever that day
lies lies lies and when the pressure got
to be too much
when it became abundantly clear that
they were lying dr sean conley came out
again on sunday
and seemed very confused about how time
works and what day it is
seeming to have uh almost of issues
better served for a physics lab uh that
than
than for a medical press conference how
does time work does it go forward or
backwards
only raising more questions about the
accuracy
of the story that we are getting here is
connolly being asked about
his vague admission that trump did have
some breathing problems but everything
is fine nonetheless
there were two instances where he had
drops in oxygen can you walk us through
the second one and also i've got a
question for the lung specialist
afterwards sure yeah
yeah yesterday uh there was another
episode where he dropped down
about 93 percent here's a never feel
short of breath
uh we watched it and it returned back up
um as i said we evaluate all of these
and
given the timeline where he is in the
the course of illness
you know we we're trying to maximize
everything uh that we could do for him
and
we debated whether we'd even start it uh
the dexa
dexamethasone and we decided that in
this case
the potential benefits early on the
course probably outweighed any risks at
this time
did you give him a second round of
supplemental oxygen yesterday
uh i'd have to i'd have to check with
the nursing staff uh
um i don't think that if he did it was
very very limited
uh but it's not on oxygen um and not the
only oxygen that i ordered
that we provided was uh that friday
morning initially and about what time
was that yesterday
uh yesterday what was yesterday you said
the second instance
second incidents oh it was over the
course of the day yeah
yesterday morning yesterday what oh yeah
yesterday it was during the course of
the day
yesterday morning well wait hold on was
it in the morning or was it throughout
the day what are you talking about
even conley himself sounds confused like
he's obviously lying like he's been told
to downplay but he also seems confused
about the facts
in the next moment i'm going to play for
you
conley is called out for saying trump's
doing great and then minutes later
trump's chief of staff mark meadows came
out and admitted to the media
it's really bad we're not even sure
trump will make a full recovery at this
point in time
connolly called out about it and here's
how he how he responded
that's a steroid sir a lot of people
told us that the president was in great
shape
had been in good shape and fever-free
for the previous 24 hours
minutes after your press conference
white house chief of staff mark meadows
told reporters that the president's
vitals were very concerning over the
past 24 hours
simple question for the american people
whose statements about the president's
health should be believed
so the chief and i work side by side
and uh i think his statement was
misconstrued what he meant was that uh
24 hours ago when uh he and i were
are checking on the president that there
was that momentary episode of the high
fever
and and that temporary drop uh in the
saturation
which prompted us to act uh
expediently to move him up here
fortunately
that was really a very transient limited
episode
a couple hours later he was back up uh
mild again
um you know we i'm not going to
speculate what that
that limited episode was about so early
in the course but he's doing well
you really get the sense that conley is
just not
cut out for this lying he's doing the
lying
but he's doing it really poorly and
transparently nobody believes this guy
at this point
check this one out remember from our
last segment
that oxygen saturation below 94
is sirius coved that's the baseline
conley is asked
was trump ever saturating oxygen below
90
and conley says we don't have recordings
of that
here at the hospital kind of a weird
response so then he's asked
was oxygen saturation ever below 90
and conley says it was never in the low
80s
nobody asked about the low 80s another
obvious lie
ever ever dipped below 90.
we don't have any recordings here of
that that's right
yeah what about here at the white house
or here anything below 90 just to follow
up on her question
uh no it was below 94 it was it wasn't
down in the low 80s or anything
so okay so on the decks and methods it
is lie after lie
and from that what i interpret is
trump's saturation
did get to the 80s not the low 80s and
that's
really serious covid and then lastly
here he is explaining
the previous days absurd rosy picture
that he painted
he just says well i was trying to be
upbeat as long as were there any
teachers today to disclose that the
president had been administered
oxygen uh it's a good question so
i was trying to reflect the the uh the
upbeat attitude that the
team the president that his course of
illness has had
didn't want to give any uh any
information that might
uh steer the the course of illness in
another direction
um and in doing so uh you know it came
off
uh that we were trying to hide something
which wasn't necessarily true i love
that he says there i mean it's just
every
sentence every he says we weren't
necessarily trying to hide something
it's almost like a freudian use of the
word necessarily
you weren't necessarily trying to hide
something but you were what what does
that even mean
they lie about everything and we have to
ask why
and the answer is optics given that
there's an election
in 30 days or less i think it's 29 days
at this point 28 days
period has donald trump gotten to the
point where they're going to send them
back to the white house you might
know more than i've been able to tell
you now because something may have
changed in the next few hours
we will follow it we will cover it they
are very very worried here about
the impact of this on the election and
we'll talk about that after the break